PLAYING HIS 100th NHL
GAME TONIGHT.
THE GAME
NUMBER 63,OK A NICE
LEAD PASS AND GET
SOME SPEED GOING
COMING ACROSS  THE
OFFENSE OF
>> Jack: D,
>> Andy: NICE HRONEK, D
AROUND THE HORN,
FABBRI, S, THEY MOVED
THAT PUCK REALLY
WELL, BOSTON  TRYING
TO BE AGGRESSIVE,
SEULA ON
THE SLOT.
GRZELCYK, TO CARLO, ETC
GOT A PIECE.
COIL, TO THE
ENDBOARDS, LETTY,  AND
POWER PLAY GOAL,
BERGERON MOVED FROM U J
FOCUS ON 37 IN BLACK
AND GOLD AFTER THE
FACE-OFF WHEN YOU GO
TOWARDS  FABBRI, AND
CARLO TOTO
CARLO.
GRZELCYK, OF OUR
FR DEEP,
PASTRNAK THE TOUCH,
McAVOY JUMP
PLAY BY USING THE NET
AS HIS AL
THE ONE-HOPPER.
TAYLOR HALL, WITH A
LOT OF I
BY THE WINGS, DOWN
THE WALL, KEEPING
PLAYS ALIVE.
DOORS, FILIP HRONEK
GIVES IT TO MARCHAND
TO BERGERON, HE SUPPORT
PLAY BY MAMARCHAND.
THIS EXPLAINS TO SOME
EXTENT
TO EUROPE, PLAYED
THERE LAST YEAR, AND D !
HIS SEVENTH HAT TRICK.T
SLOT, AND IF YOU
WATCH THEM ON  A
QUALITY SCORING  RAYMON
SCORESAND ONE, AND
CARLO GOES TO TRY TO
BOSTON THIS SEASON.CHEC
THAT'S NOT GOALTENDER
INTERFERENCE, IT'S A
NICE FOLLOW-UP, GOOD
LUCK.
OFF THE SKATE, JAKE
GOOD BOUNCE IN
THE NEUTRAL ZONE, BUT
THEY EARNED IT,
GETTING THE PUCKS ,
TRY TO GET IT NOSEK, LA
THE SAVE
HE SCORES!IN LATE.